95 year-old mariano oginski often thinks
back to his days on the western front he
was 24 when he joined a Polish Armored
Division he was sent to Britain to help
liberate northern France but when the
Allies landed in Normandy suave in skis
division had to stay behind to wait for
equipment from the US
when the first troops arrived in France
we were really envious we'd spent a lot
of time training for that operation so
we were keen to join the Allies in
Normandy as soon as possible and they
were waiting for us to our division was
supposed to be on the front line and
move things forward quickly the Polish
division reached France at the end of
July they had the crucial role of
closing off an escape route for German
soldiers at fundation woth after three
days and nights of intense fighting they
succeeded thousands of German soldiers
were surrounded by Allied forces when we
were given the command to fire I look
down the hill and saw endless numbers of
German soldiers please forgive me I
don't really want to talk about it we
just shot into the masses there were
masses of Germans that battle led to the
liberation of France so well Vince key
wanted to press on and liberate his
homeland but he wasn't able to return
until after the war Poland was then
under Soviet control many of his
comrades emigrated this is one of my
comrades we were in a tank together he
emigrated to Canada sadly he died
recently his wife died too we stayed in
contact for a long time and visited each
other several times so Vince key will be
attending this year's commemorations in
Normandy where he hopes to meet with
both former friends and foes I'd be
happy to meet German veterans there too
I don't believe in living in the past we
must not forget but we need to look to
the future too I will shake hands with
the Germans and wish them all the best
at the age of 95 Marianne suave in skeet
will be the oldest better
and from Poland he'll return to the
scene of his worst battle an area that
he now hopes will be a place of
reconciliation